you
your crawler tractor is an important
piece of equipment used in heavy
construction and road maintenance
activities you as the operator can
minimize downtime and repairs each
agency has its own specific maintenance
checks it is your responsibility to
ensure that they are followed on your
machine this videotape will show you the
general methods and procedures for
operator daily maintenance on crawler
tractors but more important it tells you
why these procedures are necessary each
agency has their own specific
maintenance activities and each
equipment manufacturer as its
recommended procedures it is your
responsibility that none of the special
requirements for your machine are
overlooked follow along as our operator
goes through the complete set of daily
maintenance activities by using a
checkoff list you can divide your
inspections into four groups of
activities the pre-start check the
warm-up check
but daily operating check
and the shutdown check if during these
activities problems are discovered
follow your local guidelines to
determine corrective procedures now we
can look at these activities in detail
the first activity is the pre-start
check the pre-start check is a
walk-around inspection for damaged or
worn parts and fluid leaks it also
includes checking the tractors fluid
levels and the engine's air filter
system daily attention needs to be given
to the tracks gradually through use the
tracks will become worn check the
sprocket teeth as they are worn down the
seat between them will become oblong
next inspect the pins and bushings at
various points along the chain where
hear causes the bushing to become flat
on one side finally check the rollers by
passing your hand across their wear
surface this surface should feel flat
and smooth all these points are
important ask your supervisor for your
tractors wear specifications timely
maintenance of these components will
extend their service life and postpone
costly repairs now that the tracks have
been inspected you can move to the
crawler tractor attachments inspect the
dozer blade the push frame the pins the
cutting edges and the end bits if the
cutting edge and end bits are worn to
the dozer blade report it to your
supervisor make sure there are no loose
nuts or bolts and as part of this
inspection you should also look for weld
defects here again timely maintenance
can save costly repairs if your koala
tracker is equipped with a ripper it
should be inspected in the same way
again
pay close attention to wear of the
ripper teeth if a replacement is needed
follow your local guidelines
you can continue the free start check by
looking for any fluid leaks fluid leaks
will affect the safe and efficient
operation of your tractor first look on
the ground under the engine compartment
for spots or stains any spots here alert
you to engine fluid leaks now inspect
for hydraulic oil leaks the hoses should
be checked for cracks make sure they are
not pinched leaks from the blade angle
and lift cylinders are most likely found
at the cylinder seals
finally as you move toward the engine
compartment you can finish this
inspection by checking the lift cylinder
hose connections in the engine
compartment leaks may occur at the
filter bowl seals inspect all filters
for leakage fill the bottom of the oil
and fuel filter bowls to see if there is
any fluid running down the side of the
bowls although they are not subject to
leaks the fan belts are part of the
cooling system and can at this time be
checked for wear and tautness the proper
operation of the fan will help control
the temperature of the engine coolant
now that we have inspected the crawler
tractor for leaks we must see if the
fluids are out the correct operating
levels begin with the engine coolant
level make sure that the fluid in the
radiator is at the level required for
your particular machine as specified by
your supervisor add more coolant if
needed it is a good practice not to
perform this check if the engine has
recently been operated since the coolant
might still be under pressure this
pressure if released by removing the cap
could cause serious injury to you in the
engine compartment check the engine oil
level the oil must be at the proper
level on the dipstick if the oil is
below the indicator mark do not run the
engine until the proper type and amount
of oil is added this completes the fluid
level checks in the engine compartment
now check the fluid level in the
hydraulic oil tank a dipstick for sight
gauge is provided for this purpose in
our case it is a sight gauge the
hydraulic system runs the dozer and
Ripper attachments as well as your
steering clutches if needed and the
proper type of hydraulic fluid to the
full mark
next you will need to drain condensation
and sediment from the fuel tank to do
this a drain is provided at the
bottom of the fuel tank
open the drain until all condensation
and sediment have been removed never
perform this operation while smoking or
with an open flame in the area
after the fluence system has been
inspected move on to the engine's air
filter system begin with an inspection
of the pre cleaner this tractor is
equipped with a free cleaner screen if
dust or other material have accumulated
on the screen clean it to clean the pre
cleaner first take it off with a stiff
brush remove any build-up from the
screen
don't hit the pre cleaner against a hard
surface this could cause serious damage
daily cleaning of the pre cleaner will
greatly reduce the clogging of the air
cleaner elements your equipment may have
a device that indicates when to clean or
replace the air cleaner element when the
indicator shows red the operator should
replace the air cleaner element if no
new elements are available notify your
supervisor in the interim the operator
should clean the old element in the
following manner to clean a dirty
element remove it if compressed air is
available clean the element by blowing
from the center outward while directing
the air up and down the pleats the
element can be checked to see if it is
clean by placing a light bulb inside and
viewing the penetration of light through
the pleated paper of the element if
compressed air is not available then
clean the element by tapping it with the
palm of your hand
do not pound it on a hard surface it
could damage the filter when the element
is clean reinstall it making sure that
the housing is correctly sealed this
will ensure proper air filtration
through the system never operate the
engine without the element in place as
this can cause extensive engine damage
now will be a good time to inspect the
battery make sure the battery is
securely fastened down
you should also inspect the battery
cables clamps and connections for
tightness and corrosion remove the
battery filler caps and check the fluid
levels if needed fill each cell to just
above the top of the battery plates and
separators with clean distilled water
never fill the cell to the top or allow
the fluid to drop below the top of the
battery plate and separators follow your
local guidelines when working with
batteries a word of caution all
batteries give off explosive gas there
should be no open flame or smoking
permitted around the battery now for
your last pre start check your crawler
tractor should have a meter that
registers the number of hours of engine
operation record the hours registered to
determine when you need to notify your
supervisor that periodic maintenance on
your crawler tractor is needed before we
go on to the next set of checks this is
a good time to stop the video and review
the inspection steps up to this point
in the last segment we finished the
pre-start check now you can move on to
the second activity which is the
equipment warm-up check the equipment
warm-up check helps you determine if the
crawler tractor is operating properly
before you leave the parking area before
starting the engine be sure all persons
are clear of the tractor all control
levers are in the neutral position and
that all attachments are grounded now
start the engine let the engine warm up
for five to ten minutes even in hot
weather this allows the oil pressure to
build up and lubricate all the moving
parts of the engine it also allows the
cooling system to reach operating
temperatures listen to your engine if
you hear anything unusual shut the
equipment down and call your supervisor
the panel gauges give information about
the engine performance we can look at
these gauges individually to make sure
they are operating in their normal
ranges does the app meter read on the
positive side are the oil and hydraulic
pressures in the safe zone if equipped
with a fuel gauge is the gauge
functioning is the fuel tank full is the
engine temperature gauge reading in the
safe zone is the transmission pressure
or temperature gauge in the safe zone
also
before we can continue you must first
lift the attachments from the rest
position while we do this we can also
observe their operation raise the dozer
blade up from its rest position tilt it
forward and by does it extend and
retract fully and smoothly if your
tractor has a ripper attachment raise
and lower it also for the final warm-up
check you need to put the tractor in
motion first release the parking brake
now apply the brakes the brake bands
should provide good stopping ability in
both directions
as part of the steering system you
should test the steering clutches do
they engage and release smoothly in
response to your controls as you move
the tractor from side to side all these
checks are critical for safe and
efficient equipment operation do not
begin working until the list has been
completed and all the checks have proven
satisfactory the third operator
maintenance activity the daily operating
check is carried out while the tractor
is working during daily operations you
should monitor your equipments
performance specifically listen for
unusual noises and read your gauges be
aware of any changes in the performance
of your equipment we can look at these
individually listen for unusual engine
and equipment noises noises can be an
indication if component failure read
your gauges watch pressures and
temperatures closely if any gauge reads
in the danger zone shut down the tractor
inspect the system and notify your
supervisor as part of the daily
operations you should monitor equipment
performance in particular track
adjustment improperly adjusted tracks
cost money in downtime and accelerated
track wear tracks that are too loose
whip at high speeds causing needless
we're on track roller flanges track
chain links and sprocket teeth tracks
that are too tight with extra stress on
undercarriage drivetrain components and
wastes horsepower
the fourth and last daily maintenance
activity is your shutdown check this
activity helps prepare your tractor for
the following workday find a level area
to park your crawler tractor rest all
attachments on the ground and set the
parking brake
this secures your equipment and prevents
injury to anyone tampering with the
machine while it is parked now let the
engine idle for approximately five
minutes before shutting down this
reduces the pressures in your hydraulic
system that can cause leaks or damages
to the seals or hoses before you leave
the tractor cab record the our meter
reading against the time recorded at
startup this is a check to see if the
meter is working and will help in
scheduling the equipment's periodic
maintenance now is a good time to fill
your fuel tank filling your fuel tank is
a good maintenance practice it minimizes
water condensation when refuelling be
sure all equipment is clean this
prevents any contaminants from entering
the fuel tank since these are flammable
liquids do not smoke or have an open
flame in the area part of your
responsibility also includes lubrication
lubrication extends the operating life
of your crawler tractor follow the
manufacturer's guidelines for the proper
lubrication of your tractor one way to
make it easier for you to identify the
daily lubrication points is to have the
marked finally using a hand tool clean
away dirt or material that has built up
on tracks whish frame dozer blade and
the rest of the equipment that completes
the detailed description of the four
major daily operator maintenance
activities now we will review each group
of activities once more the first
activity is the pre-start check this is
a walk-around inspection for damaged or
worn parts leaks fluid level checks and
inspection of the engines air filter
system look for damaged or worn parts
such as the attachments and tracks it
also includes checking for fluid leaks
of the hydraulic cooling and engine
systems inspect all the fluid levels
such as oil coolant and hydraulics drain
the fuel tank of dirt and condensation
finally inspect the engines air filter
system the second activity is the
equipment warm-up check this inspection
is made from inside the cab while the
engine is warming up listen for unusual
engine noises be sure to read the gauges
check the dozer and Ripper attachments
and test the steering and brakes before
beginning work the third activity is the
operating check the operating checks
during the workday include frequently
listening for unusual noises reading
gauges and being aware of changes in the
performance of the equipment the fourth
and last activity is the shutdown check
part the equipment on a level surface
rest all hydraulic attachments on the
ground set the parking brake idle the
engine for approximately 5 minutes prior
to shutdown fill the fuel tank grease
all mechanical joints and clean away
dirt and debris this videotape included
general maintenance procedures and may
be modified to meet the individual
requirements of your agency there may
also be additional safety inspections
required check your operator maintenance
guidelines this concludes the program on
koala tractor operator daily maintenance
following these procedures will help to
ensure that your crawler tractor is
properly maintained and stays in good
operating can
station
you